there is an absolutely insane
criminal disgusting
immoral and depraved series of
allegations
against donald trump and his family
which are completely unsurprising
if you've been paying attention for the
last four to five years
a business insider exclusive
investigation has revealed
that donald trump's son-in-law jared
kushner helped to create
a trump campaign shell corporation which
secretly paid
trump's family and spent on their behalf
uh 170 million dollars
in campaign re-election money um it
actually spent more than that in total
but at issue are about 170 million
dollars 617 million dollars is the total
amount in play here
now we had rumblings about this story
months ago i've been covering this story
for months
you all seemed very interested in it the
number of emails i got about it was huge
i did a story back in july called trump
campaign laundering millions to his own
family uh in september the
investigations into this were heating up
and i covered it in a segment called
trump panicking accused of laundering
170 million dollars
this is all part of the same scam about
which we now have more specific
information so listen to these details
which are being presented by a source
familiar with this operation
to business insider the way this scam
worked
is that jared kushner who is trump's
son-in-law
and also a white house senior advisor if
you can believe that
uh directed his uh sister uh his uh
uh his sister-in-law trump's
daughter-in-law lara trump that's eric
trump's wife
gotta keep all of it straight jared
kushner directs lara trump
uh and mike mike pence's nephew john
pence
and trump campaign cfo sean dahlman to
be on the board of this shell company
that they
created the company is called american
made
media consultants corporation and
american made media consultants llc
now that should ring a bell because this
is related to the name of donald trump's
former campaign manager
brad parscale's company and what they
did is they spent in total
617 million dollars that's about half of
the 1.26 billion
that trump's campaign fundraised and
some of the spending was legitimate so
the issue is not the 617 million
the issue is that about 170 million of
that money
is essentially laundered money as
salaries to trump's family and others
as well as a slush fund of all sorts of
spending
why did they do this the reason they did
this
is believed to be to avoid trump's
donors
finding out that a whole bunch of their
money
is actually just being funneled back out
to trump's family and friends
the next step is that if the department
of justice finds that this was done
knowingly and willfully
they would open up an investigation but
the big bombshell
is that several sources from the justice
department and
fec told the business insider
that there are investigators that may
already be looking into the campaign's
activity so there's a few different
things to talk about here number one
is anybody surprised to hear this if
you've been paying attention you
couldn't possibly be surprised about
this
number two i don't actually know that
trump's donors would really care if they
knew about this and what i mean by that
is
lara trump was getting a hundred and
eighty thousand a year you know a whole
bunch of people were getting a 180 grand
a year and all this
all this money was being laundered into
companies held by trump's family and
friends
if you went with this information to a
lot of trump's followers
i don't think they'd be mad you would
say to them aren't aren't you upset that
for every hundred bucks you donated 50
was funneled to this company
and then a bunch of that was funneled
like to trump's family just for going
around and doing interviews and
not not really doing much uh and i think
most of them would say no
trump has a great family and they're all
helping him win
and uh i i'm i'm hap the point is
i think a lot of trump's uh donors
would rationalize this money being
laundered anyway
now number three here's something
disgustingly ironic
the defense bill that donald trump wants
to veto
for ridiculous uh uh reasons
also contains a crackdown on the use of
shell companies to launder money it's
just like a side note
that's number three and then number four
pardons
you know how we've been talking about is
trump going to
preemptively pardon his family members
jared ivanka whoever we weren't sure
why trump would think he needs to
preemptively pardon them well
if jared kushner is being investigated
for being part of this shell company
money laundering scheme
that would be a great explanation it
would fit very neatly into the puzzle
of why donald trump is reportedly
considering pardoning people like jared
kushner and others
look at what we've been able to find out
during the trump administration about
what they've done
imagine what will come out once this guy
is out of office
truly stunning and remarkable i want to
take a second to tell you about one of
our sponsors
s h masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and
other protective gear for covid 19 and
they're giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over a hundred and
fifty dollars you can get there by going
to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david